what is churn rate sure and rate is how
quickly people get sick of something and
so it's it's you know a kid will play
with the toy for five minutes and then
get sick of it move to something else
and that's churn rate and so the faster
the churn rate the the worse it is
because people get sick your stuff in a
much quicker rate and so how you're
flipping through the channels you you
land on it on a show how how long you're
going to give that before you flip to
the next channel on the radio how long
I'm going to give a song before you flip
to the next song and so churn rates
typically in a competitive environment
are very high because there's so many
options now I'm just like bouncing from
things I think the thing the thing the
thing the thing to thing and that that
you know back in the 50s when there was
just radio then people would sit and
listen to one radio station for hours
and just listen to radio dramas and news
and and they wouldn't flip to anything
because there was only one thing that
they could do now with all the stuff
that we have to do all the entertainment
options the oversaturated tsunami of
entertainment that is around us all the
time
churn rates are very high and and that's
bad for creators so we now have to think
of how we create how do we how do we
create a brand that lowers the churn
rate of people how do we keep them
engaged for longer and in more
meaningful ways into our brand in our
stories and and that's something very
important because because the longer you
can engage the audience and the longer
the valuable engagement takes place the
more chance you have to then convert
them into that now a loyal audience
member or ultimately to what I call a
brand evangelists somebody who's not
just watching your stuff but actually
helping market your stage you see the
new Game of Thrones this week hey you
should check out this show you could go
watch this movie because it's awesome if
you can if you can convert them into
that that's where that's the sweet spot
because then when you get people one
loyal to your brand to
that are so loyal that they're marketing
your brand you start to solve some that
PNA issue we talked about earlier of
having to rely on so much PA because
you've activated your fan base to do
something valuable but you're not you're
never going to activate the fan base if
they only engage with your stories for
10 seconds at a time so now we have to
slow that down get them engaged and and
have that engagement be valuable and if
you can do that then all of a sudden
you've separated yourself in the
marketplace and solve the major problem
in the in the industry which is these
hiring rate issues so does that mean we
keep our content shorter or give them
breaks well it's it depends it depends
on your content but the the thing that
the thing that people love most is story
we live in an entertainment culture and
people love story more than anything
else and so again whereas attention
spans maybe seemingly low they they're
no longer low if you can engage them
with story if you have a great story
they'll watch it for ten hours in a row
and that's fine
so so the so a 10 hour binge watch is a
very low churn rate because they're
watching for 10 hours are turning off so
this is for technique and craft come
into play if you can understand how to
hook them hook them fast give them new
and better things as you go through the
story then all of a sudden you're
starting to lower that churn rate but at
the same time it's how do we create
multiple engagements that you know if
you're if you're operating just a
network television you have one one our
engagement every week and that's it and
so now between one your one one our
engagements you have a week in between
right so now if we can start filling
that week with some other things so as a
companion web series like they do on AMC
maybe a digital comic that gives them
more valuable parts of the story that
bridges the gap between episodes what
you do every single time that you have
your audience engage with valuable
content
valuable story then slowly you're going
to start to lower their turn rate until
you get them to the point that they'll
watch your stuff for ten hours typically
they won't do that at the beginning it's
a process of getting them to that point
to where they'll say okay I'll watch
your stuff for ten hours
I'll watch 60 hours of your content in a
month through a binge watch because
you've you've you've spent the time and
made the investment into me as an
audience member to a point of where I'm
willing to give you this investment into
your brand right and so and the only way
to get them to that point is to have as
much and as many valuable engagements as
humanly possible and the thing that they
value most is story so it's not just
marketing and promotions that's a big
trend media misconception and it's all
advertising and marketing it's really
still it's the bestest story based stuff
how do I create story based engagement
so like at the South by self South by
Southwest they had the the show Bates
Motel created a new a replica of the
Bates Motel that you could actually rent
out a room and stay in while you're in
South by Southwest that's cool marketing
but it's not transmedia because it
didn't give you any more of a story
because because what happens is is when
it was time to go for the festival they
would open the door and they would leave
the room they'd come back at night and
you know they're very limited time in
the room but if for summary is some way
like they took a picture up the wall and
all of a sudden Norman had written a
message behind that picture if they
would take the Gideon's Bible out of the
out of the desk and open up and it's not
getting the Bible at all there's an
object in there maybe it's a it's a
journal that's been written by Norman
get given more insight into his
character insight into some storylines
there's creaky floorboards that you
could pop up in the stuff underneath
there like you flip over the mattress
and there's stuff in the mattress maybe
stuff actually hidden inside the
mattress you have to rip open to find if
you can extend the story so in such a
way that the hotel room becomes part of
the story now now what's happened is
is you've created longer points of
engagement for that fan base and that
the fans that are in the room maybe
don't even want to go outside because
the whole room is part of the story that
they love presumably they don't stay in
the basement tell unless they watch that
Bates Motel show or even if they do
maybe it's a mechanism to get them to
watch the show but you're going to have
a better chance to get them to watch the
show if you start to seed the story and
extend the store in a really interesting
way so maybe you never watch the show
before but based on this experience that
you have and all these weird little
story clues and interactions that you
discover in this room now it makes you
even you have a greater chance of
checking out far beyond just a marketing
experience and so so it's the it's it's
the how is how do we create lots of
really valuable story based engagements
for the fan base and the every single
one of those engagements creates a lower
churn rate and so maybe the churn rate
is very high and for somebody that's the
I'm a DD I'm distracted I like to do 100
things I never watch long you know
long-form TV I just like watching web
stuff YouTube stuff all this stuff if
you can just slowly start giving story
based engagement to that audience member
and then you start to lower the turn
right lower the turn right lower the
turn rate lower the turn rate to
eventually you can get them to a point
to say okay I'll watch your step stuff
for 10 hours in a sitting because you've
give you've invested into me so much
already
so make sense - okay great
you